many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism this is a a
commonly asked question and it's a good
one why do the Stoics only recognize
four virtues it seems like there's a lot
of other virtues that they're leaving
off of their list so what are the four
virtues that the Stoics do in fact
recognize they're often called the
cardinal virtues and these are wisdom
justice courage and temperance so why
didn't the Stoics talk about all sorts
of other virtues like great-souled
Nisour control of anger or generosity or
honesty so there's a good answer to this
there's a very simple and
straightforward answer to this which is
that the Stoics did in fact talk about a
whole bunch of other virtues and they
grouped them under these four primary
virtues now when you hear that answer
you might say what wait a second dr.
Sandler I've looked at a lot of stoic
blog posts and podcasts and websites and
books and I've only seen them talk about
four virtues and I know that other
virtue ethicists talk about a whole
range of other virtues so so why is this
confusion arising well that's a good
secondary question the answer to that
has to do with a little bit of history
we only possess a small selection of
what it is that classic stoic authors
wrote and what we have is what we call
late stoicism which are the writers
during the Roman Empire who for the most
part are assuming an audience that's
very conversant with the existing stoic
literature that we don't have access to
in that existing stoic literature as we
know from other texts the Stoics did in
fact have these four main virtues which
they went into great explanation about
some of those explanations included
telling us which other Verte
shoes fell under those so because
contemporary stoic literature for the
most part is drawing on sources like
Epictetus marcus aurelius seneca we're
not actually getting a detailed
discussion of all these other virtues
although they mention them quite
frequently now if you want to know more
about how the Stoics understood the
entire range of the virtues where would
you go there's three classic source
texts that would be very useful for you
and these are often considered you might
say Advanced Study in stoicism so a lot
of beginners don't encounter these one
of them is deities Laertes lives of the
Philosopher's which has an entire book
on the stoic school where he gives a
summary of the stoic doctrines and he
talks about the primary virtues and then
some of the secondary virtues another
would be arias did a mrs. epitome of
stoic ethics that I'll read from in just
a moment where he summarizes what the
stoic teaching is on these as well and
gives you a listing the third source
that I think would be particularly
useful would be going to Cicero
particularly on duties although you can
find this in some of his other works
where he talks about what the virtues
what these four cardinal virtues of
wisdom justice temperance and courage
are really all about and you can see
that they cover a very wide range
including things that other virtue
ethics recognized as separate virtue in
arias didymus is summary or epitome of
stoic ethics he tells us that there are
these four primary virtues and then
there's a number of other virtues that
can be grouped under these primary
virtues so he tells us to wisdom our
subordinated soundness of judgment
circumspection shrewdness sensibleness
soundness of aim and ingenuity so
each of these is a intellectual virtue
you might say to temperance or
self-restraint
are subordinated orderliness propriety
modesty and self-control for courage or
bravery are subordinated perseverance
intrepid nice great heartedness stout
hardness and industriousness and finally
to justice subordinated piety kindness
good fellowship and fair dealing
doesn't that list cover every possible
disposition that might be called a
virtue in some other moral theory no but
if we dig around in the stomach text we
will find a lot of other things that we
consider to be virtues it might be
missing on the stoic list to actually be
there talked about by say epictetus or
Marcus Aurelius or Seneca as part of
virtue if we read through Cicero's works
this is also particularly helpful
because you see him assimilating many
other things to stoic virtue to bring
this to a close the Stoics do in fact
talk about a number of virtues it's just
that they do so in a way that gives
primacy to these four cardinal virtues
of wisdom justice temperance and courage
and that arranges the other virtues
underneath them so there aren't any
virtues actually missing in the stoic
schema it's just a matter of how we
approach the text and so there's a bit
of a historical reason for why these
confusions arise if you found this
answer helpful for you then please share
it with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Sadler